I'm Doe Deer.
I have a channel on YouTube
called Doe Deer Wonderland
where I do doll restorations.
This is a 1964 Ponytail Swirl Barbie.
They had a limited run of about two years.
They were basically the last dolls
to represent '50s glamour.
It makes them really
valuable to collectors.
The hair is basically a mess.
It's frizzy.
The paint has basically chipped away.
She has a bald spot, which
I'm going to be filling in.
So, first I'm going to wash the doll
using dishwashing soap and a toothbrush.
Then I'm going to put fabric
conditioner in her hair
and comb it through.
I use just a normal hairbrush,
and then I go over it with a fine comb
once all the kinks are out.
Next, I'm going to reroot
the doll using nylon hair.
That's a specific tool for doll rerooting.
So it's a needle that's been cut.
So I take the hank of hair,
cut it to the length that I need,
then I put it around my finger,
and using the rerooting tool
I just pick up small sections
and insert them into the doll's head.
Then I'm going to glue the hair in place.
You glue it on the inside of the head
so that the hair doesn't come out
when you brush it or work with it.
Then I boil the hair to keep
it down while I work on it.
Boiling water basically
calms the hair fibers
and makes sure they lay in the position
that you want them to.
I am giving her a haircut
and putting her hair in rollers.
The hair that you order
is not the correct length.
You're always going to have some overhang,
so you're just going to want to cut that
to match the doll's length.
I just wrap the sections
with aluminum foil
and then roll them around the rollers.
The rollers I made myself using Fimo clay.
I go over her legs with a sandpaper block
to address the scratches.
As her face has become a bit green,
I'm going to counteract that
using soft pastels with no primer.
The vinyl is basically like human skin.
It absorbs anything you put on it.
I go over it using
a mixture of red and yellow and orange.
Then I'm repainting her
face using acrylic paint.
The eyeliner is chipped,
so there's pieces of it missing.
The lips have faded to a white,
which is common for dolls like this.
I use a thin paintbrush so
I can detail all the makeup.
These are specifically
made for detail work.
Then I apply a semiglossy
varnish on the paint job.
The varnish that I use,
it just helps preserve
the paint that I applied,
and it gives it a semiglossy finish.
Her nails are faded,
and I need to go over them
to make them decent again.
The original hairstyle of the doll
was basically a low ponytail
with sideswept bangs
and a flip around the ponytail.
I brush out her hair.
I am going to tie the hair in
the back in a low ponytail.
Then I use hair mousse to
keep the hair in place.
And I hide the elastic
band with a strand of hair.
Then I set the curl around
my finger using hair mousse.